he is the golden globe-winning actor who
currently stars in HBO's succession
please welcome Brian Cox
[Music]
[Applause]
we got it
all right it was cold so great to meet
you lovely to meet you I really didn't
meet you many many years ago but you
probably don't remember I don't I I was
stoic I was so stunned
you were actually I remembered I could
feel the waft coming across me yeah it
was I did a thing called Nuremberg and I
won an Emmy and you sat behind me I was
just gonna so funny I was gonna say to
you I first became aware of you from
when you played goring that's right yeah
yeah and then that had to be like 25
years ago it was a long time with
something like and and I swear to God I
said that and that is a riveting actor
and when you got this part on succession
and look I'm a fan of Netflix I've said
this before I know those guys and I
certainly may need them someday so I
don't ever want to piss them off no but
I love Netflix but like Netflix as a
thousand shows oh yeah I want to see
that HBO always has one show we're like
I am so dying to see that one and your
show is that show sorry for touching you
[Applause]
[Music]
it's crazy
and you know I know they've said the
character in succession is is Murdoch
but it seems more Trump to me because
it's more intelligent than Trump a way
more Intel any more intelligent than
Trump but what they have in common is
that you hate him for what he does but
there is something that people like
about balls the cheer balls on it must
be fun to play a guy first of all to be
a leading man yeah but especially
welcome to sex symbol is really
I was doing a thing and presenting for
the new season and my wife was sitting
next to somebody out in the audience and
and I came on and this woman who was
sitting next to my wife she said or that
Brian Cox he's so hot my wife said thank
you so embarrassed I'm so sorry said but
no it's it's it's it's it's a great role
you know you have to wait nearly 60
years before you get a role like that
and it's fantastic but again
I gotta say HBO like you're thinking
about James Gandolfini yeah
in Sopranos or Steve Buscemi in the ORD
walk empire you nobody else yeah we cast
these people no but they're riveting and
they are sexy oh yeah that's amazing so
okay so you I read left home at 11:00 no
no no that's exaggeration I left home
just I was on the cusp of my 15th but I
was on 14 still ridiculous yeah I mean
in America I mean we don't let them like
go to school well I never left home I
just went to work that was all oh I got
very bad information
no no well actually my home left me
because of family circumstances so I was
prey on my own but and that's the
Scottish way it's the way of poverty
actually that's what it's about
and that made you a socialist of course
yeah yeah and subsequently well really a
social democrat and subsequently I thank
you subsequently a supporter of my
country Scotland which is as a separate
country as a separate country because
it's been watching I mean because it's
been treated like a [ __ ] pile for long
enough so it was my ancestors iron well
I'm a Mi'kmaq which is an Irish scholar
the word the same people they are the
Celtic people
we have all those memories in our DNA I
don't think people realize that when the
English conquered your country and my
old country they were conquering
countries where people did not speak
English that's right that like they
think they think they were kind of a
kindred spirits anyway the Irish didn't
speak English in 1850 and the Scots yes
no can understand it's a different
language
no it's it's I mean you know I came to
me because when I grew up when I was a
kid and I used to live on a place I grew
up in a town called Dundee which is my
hometown and I used to look at the the
River Tay and I used to I couldn't wait
to get across it and I did get across it
and then when I now in that and those
days it was North Britain that's what it
was because we had been through two wars
so that we'd never and the Scots have
been like cannon fodder and particularly
in the First World War and the Second
World War it was you know it was pretty
even Stephen all round but we had not
found ourselves in our country being
taken away from us at an earlier time
when we lost our Parliament so and then
we had you know the famous claudin and
all of that but our independence had
gone and we've always been treated very
feudal II and that still goes on you
have a great accent because there's a
hint of it yes but not enough to go what
the [ __ ] is he but yeah so but let me
ask you about this you must have went
through brexit it was horrible okay but
I feel like brexit was a harbinger of
what was going to happen in this country
and we did well I didn't pay attention
because it it was soon after the Donald
Trump got elected it was you know and
you have Boris Johnson who looks like
Donald Trump we have these Alaia
yeah very much I know the world is ruled
by liars well it always that Netanyahu
in Israel laia Russia lion
okay politicians are generally liars
it's well occasionally you get a good
one you
a good liar or a good politician okay a
good politics what I'm asking you is you
just did the Labour Party just lost her
tremendous election they ran a guy named
Jeremy Corbyn yeah look show the picture
he looks just like Bernie Sanders and he
is the seventh
he's a 70 something socialist and they
thought oh you know what the working
class is gonna love this guy he was
promising the same thing yeah as Bernie
Sanders is promising big social programs
taxes on the rich to pay for it and the
working class saw it as pie in the sky
and said no thanks you lost the worst
defeat since 1935 it's terrible but then
that's also partly to do with the whole
little Englander mentality and also a
mentality which oh by the way I better
take these bloody glasses off sorry I
mean what happened it's an interesting
thing I mean his policies were
interesting policies but he has the
charisma of a failed geography teacher
and which one are we talking both all
right well actually Trump wouldn't
understand anything about geography but
- but I'm talking about problems but
what I think was really interesting is
his policies weren't bad there were good
policies but the problem was he couldn't
sell them and the problem was that we
are so under it's so interesting to see
what happened you know part you know
areas which were totally socialist was
totally for such a long long time areas
by the way by the way in which in the
last ten years due to austerity
particularly in that area from the
Tories the death rate of women increased
that increased women were dying in a
much earlier age and they had done
previously and that's because of
conservative austerity and that is what
and it was crazy to me that they didn't
they didn't bite on the bullet they
didn't say oh let's go with it let's go
with it
because a jaw going teacher couldn't
sell it
you